oder wird sich denn heute bestimmt schon
zum zehnten mal wird könnte ja was ist
oder was könnte ich ein essen dann
werden wir wieder ein
da merkt man erst mal wie oft am tag an
essen denkt
[Musik]
tage- oder wochenlang nichts oder sehr
wenig essen gibt es als brauch in allen
weltreligionen und tiere machen es
schließlich auch gezwungenermaßen ein
königspinguinen kann fünf monate ohne
nahrung auskommen lebt nur von seinen
fettpolstern und verliert einfach mal
die hälfte seines körpergewichts da
können wir menschen nur staunen dabei
ist unser ständiges vorteil auch nicht
gerade das was unser körper braucht
frühstück mittag abendessen letztendlich
essen wir immer wenn wir nicht gerade
schlafen
dabei könnten wir 30 tage lang oder
länger ohne feste nahrung übernehmen und
gesund ist sporadisches fasten auch da
sind sich sämtliche experten einig die
insulinempfindlichkeit steigt das beugt
diabetes typ 2 vor entzündungsreaktionen
wert verringert und das betriebssystem
kann sich mal ein bisschen erholen das
sind nur einige von vielen vorteil es
ist der erste könnte nicht zu mir nehme
seit 36 stunden aber für den kopf ihr
könnt es doch sicherlich auch dass ihr
euch vor hunger auf nichts mehr
konzentrieren könnt macht ein längeres
fasten nicht einfach nur dumm
der kuchen
kurzfristig schon aber langfristig
leiden die kognitiven fähigkeiten und zu
einem erhöhten blutzuckerspiegel ein
dauerhaft erhöhter blutzuckerspiegel
führte bei studienteilnehmern zu
schlechteren ergebnissen bei
gedächtnistests außerdem kann man ihn
fastenkliniken folgendes beobachten nach
etwa drei sehr harten tagen steigt dich
denn du der fast 40
vielleicht weil sie ins geschieht völlig
raum sind na ja so ähnlich man muss das
so sehen bei unseren vorfahren kamen
bisher durchaus mal vor dass man drei
tage lang nichts zu essen bekam das ist
für den körper erst mal ziemlich
ermüdend ich saß die letzte stunde
einfach nur auf einem stuhl im
wohnzimmer und vaters und es häufig
anstrengend wenn man sich dann in seine
höhle schlafen legen kann es sein dass
man nie wieder aufwacht ich befürchte
ich muss einen kleinen bauern erhalten
und genau das zu verhindern wird unser
gehirn gefühle der euphorie aus damit
wir uns aufrappeln und nach nahrung
suchen durch essen nehmen wir unter
anderem die aminosäure tryptophan auf
diese ist eine vorstufe des
glückshormons serotonin
wenn wir nicht zu essen bekommen
verfallen wir deswegen zuerst in eine
art kleine depression es ist halb drei
und ich kann nichts anderes
ich wollte gerade wirklich sei ich kann
er nichts anderes essen bei längeren
fasten wie dieser mangel ausgeglichen in
den weniger von diesen glückshormon
serotonin entfernt wird und so die
konzentration wieder steigt es ist fast
halb zwölf uhr abends ich fühle mich
ziemlich fett zu verwahrt und verkörpert
also eine anti depressivum funktion die
durchs fasten in gang gebracht wird doch
bevor ihr euch jetzt euphorisch ins
fasten schritt informiert euch bitte bei
eurem ersten welchem ausmaß das für euch
gesund für denkt außerdem dass die
meisten menschen zu recht nicht in ihrem
stressigen arbeitsalltag fasten sondern
sich zu einem fast in urlaub in eine
entsprechende klinik oder ähnliche
einrichtung begeben dann gibt es noch so
genanntes intervall fasten was
gegebenenfalls etwas alltagstaugliches
also informiert euch und bitte
verwechselt fast nichts mit einer
sinnvollen diät für schnellen
gewichtsverlust schneller und
nachhaltiger gewichtsverlust schließen
sich sowieso kategorisch aus und passt
es auch keine kompensation für ein
runde ernährung schön schlau ihr habt
gerade schon so ein paar ausschnitte
gesehen ich habe ein kleines
selbstexperiment gemacht um zu testen ob
die fasten euphorie nach drei tagen auch
bei mir eintritt den pflock dazu gibt es
hier bzw ab sonntag dann auf diesem
kanal was es mit euch habt ihr schon mal
gefastet und was waren eure erfahrungen
damit schreibt in die kommentare wir
sehen dass nächsten donnerstag bis dahin
bleibt sicher